[Music]
you guys know that I try my best to stay
out of the day-to-day political
bickering and focus more on Big Ideas
and the philosophies which are behind
all the fighting this doesn't mean I'm
ignoring the issues of the moment be in
North Korea the gun debate or the
general state of trumpism but focusing
on why people believe what they believe
is far more valuable to me than adding
fuel to the fire of whatever the story
of the day might be toss in a healthy
dose of political gridlock and we seem
to have lots of people who are yelling
but very few people who are doing
there's one issue happening in American
politics right now which is a great
example of the stagnation we face but
that is totally flying under the radar
right now dozens of countries some of
them key strategic allies don't have
u.s. ambassadors because the Senate has
refused to vote on their confirmation
according to the rules of the Senate
right now the Senate needs 30 hours of
debate to confirm an ambassadorship you
can imagine with all the nonsensical
waste in d.c how impossible it would be
to spend 30 hours debating each of the
new ambassadorships when a new
administration comes in we'd be talking
about literally thousands of hours of
debate for a branch of government which
can't seem to agree on which flavor of
yogurt should be served at the Capitol
Hill commissary back in 2014 when the
Democrats controlled the Senate then
Majority Leader Harry Reid used what is
known as the nuclear option to get many
Obama appointees through the Senate in
effect Reid changed the rules so that a
simple majority rather than a 60-vote
supermajority would be enough to confirm
ambassadors federal judges and other
positions though I was firmly on the
Left at the time and I had no issue I
can remember with the Obama appointees I
was against Reid using such a drastic
tactic to me if you change the rules
when you're in power it's incredibly
obvious and probably quite deserved when
those same rules will be used against
your team when you're not in power you
can rightly blame Republicans for not
voting on the Obama appointees in 2014
just as right now you can rightly blame
Democrats for not voting on Trump
appointees in 2018
this is exactly
why people rightfully hate the political
machine in Washington it either does
nothing or it changes the rules to suit
itself while usually leaving the people
it's supposed to serve far behind the
Republicans now led by Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell could use what is known
as the nuclear option right now just as
Reid and the Democrats did back in 2014
for whatever reason though McConnell
refuses to do so some are saying he has
such an old-school affinity for the
rules of the Senate that he doesn't want
to stoop to what Reid did in a certain
way this seems like a principled
position but at this point in American
politics
I wonder if clinging on to the old ways
while your ideological opponents chisel
away at those very institutions at every
opportunity
makes much sense at all let me add
another wrinkle to this story the
highest-ranking ambassadorship that we
now have open germany has been offered
to former US spokesman for the UN
Richard Grinnell Richard is the
longest-serving UN spokesman in history
working for four different u.s.
ambassadors he's also served several
other positions in the government as
well as worked for a few other
high-level political campaigns by every
measure he's supremely qualified and
I've seen plenty of people on both sides
of the aisle that praise him as the
exact type of person that we need more
of in politics Richard and I have become
friends over the past few years and I
can personally tell you that he's truly
a decent guy who just wants to serve his
country oh and there's one other piece
to this Richard happens to be gay you
may remember back in 2012
Richard was briefly a spokesman for the
Romney campaign until the media decided
to attack an openly gay man for daring
to work for the Republican candidate
Mitt Romney thus causing Richard to step
down from the campaign because he didn't
want to be a distraction apparently
although Romney felt it was just fine to
hire a gay man and Richard felt it was
totally okay to work for Romney the
media just wouldn't let it be gay
conservatives like Richard much like
black conservatives like Larry elder or
female conservatives like nikki Haley
challenge the orthodoxy that the
Democrats must own all of these groups
of people I mentioned Richard sexuality
not because it's in
horton or even relevant unless you play
the identity politics game as so many do
in effect the Democrats are blocking an
extremely qualified openly gay man from
serving his country aren't the Democrats
and lefties supposed to be for gays
isn't that part of their intersectional
worldview immutable characteristics
often Trump qualifications if you
subscribe to this line of thinking
shouldn't this also mean supporting gay
people whose political positions you
might disagree with because you believe
in their ability to think for themselves
or perhaps the so-called tolerance ID
really isn't Pro gay or Pro any minority
they are actually only Pro those who
believe as they do now obviously you
know that I don't think anyone should be
confirmed because of their sexuality nor
should their sexuality matter in the
least when it comes to being nominated
in the first place I just think that
this particular case is interesting on
so many levels we have the gridlock of
Washington with Democrats refusing to
vote on Trump nominees we have a
majority leader in McConnell that
refuses to use his option to confirm
nominees even though the previous Senate
leader Reid did exactly just that we
have dozens of qualified candidates
waiting to do their civic duty and we
have just as many countries waiting for
our ambassadors to move there and get to
work caught in all of this mess is a
good man Richard Grinnell who I happen
to know personally who doesn't want
extra credit for being gay but just
wants to get to work how can you make a
difference in all this call your local
senator and ask their assistant at the
office why they aren't voting on these
nominees and you can also call Mitch
McConnell at his DC office by calling
two oh two two two four two five four
one actually I'm gonna give him a call
right now
[Music]
joining me today is a guy who's seen an
awful lot of people get hit in the nuts
a man who's lives in a house that
constantly seems to be getting fuller
and a stand-up comic who's new special
zero-to-sixty is now streaming on Amazon
Bob Saget welcome to the Reuben report
thank you
I'm excited to be here you're a very
smart man I cannot keep up with you
mentally but we did have dinner and I
seem to keep up with the entrees is that
why you were applying me with so much
alcohol during dinner - kind of dumb me
down no I just said that we could get on
the level I wanted to see what you were
like unconscious yeah we did good
because that's the world Britain right
now that's an opposite day kind of
statement in other words years ago when
you would say I want to see what you're
like unconscious that would be a joke
but unfortunately we are in a world
right now where that's actually happened
so a lot of things that are irreverent
and could be considered funny or not
yeah and so there's this buffering that
goes on before but either way you did
not get overly inebriated and you were
more than pleasant and we had a lovely
night with both of our significant
others who we both adore and we laughed
and and we had good food yeah now we
will do it again we will do it again and
that's all I want to talk about but I
don't wanna talk about my career what do
we have as entree well I believe I had
the fish you did I think you had
something not as healthy date I think it
was maybe no I didn't know you didn't
say you had some kind of chicken
something maybe all right let's focus
here Saget come here that's a good place
to start what you just did there just
the state of political correctness let's
just do a little bit on that and then I
want to do Saget 101 all right for this
next hour I'm teaching that course at a
community college yeah yeah how many
kids are taking it it doesn't matter
whoever applies that doesn't turn me in
he let him Wally
everybody comes in yeah send a trailer
what do you think of that you're doing
this we're live to tape so right we
don't edit and this did not exist four
years ago this existed but it didn't
exist like this I mean you got millions
of people that watch this yeah this is
crazy
what do you think about that like you're
used to doing I mean obviously I want to
talk stand-up and everything else but
you do scripted series yes you do
movies things like that but you also do
you do panel on talk shows things that
are sort of they're kind of old-school
now like that's very different than
coming in here and right before we
started I said to you we're just gonna
go for it you were like whatever you
want I mean I don't have to look I can
just do that yeah you can yeah where you
get a little bit back again those are
the smallest cards I've ever seen your
interviews of microfiche it's just I
just write little silly things no that
looks all smart yeah I I love the fact
that this exists because years ago if
you wanted to go on a show and have a
one-on-one with someone it was you were
a baby but it was Tom Schneider
maybe all of you do oh yeah getting that
that you might be tiny bit older than a
baby yeah the camera was always very
close to his incredibly close at Dan
Aykroyd on Sarah Night Live and the very
beginning we know an impression of it
yeah and was this tight and he would be
smoking and tom was just talking to
camera yeah do his discourse which is
very much like a podcast is today like
Bill burr friend of mine gets up in the
morning talks for an hour once a week
it's unbelievable to listen to a lot of
our great podcasters that's the
everything has changed and in that
regard this has changed for the better
because you get to have an articulate
conversation that you can't normally
have in commercial television because
commercial television is meant to be
entertaining yeah only I don't know what
we're meant to be over here well
interesting interesting I guess yeah and
my fiancee Kelly turned me on to your
show and I said I really like him and I
like what he's talking about and you had
guests on and you were ever you're able
to be a diplomat which is very difficult
to do when you have people with
different points of view a conservative
and and a liberal which I don't
understand I don't understand any of it
yeah I just mean I understand it but I
mean we were mammals yeah we're supposed
to live yeah we're supposed to be nice
to another mammal not supposed to hunt
it and kill it depends which kind of
mammal you are at if it's delicious
yeah then you have to go for it right
yeah it's just food well we're gonna
we're gonna dive into all that because I
did note
that for you it's interesting I think
because your stand-up is so different
than your your television persona
between America's Funniest Home Video is
in Flast well they're the old ones
though but yeah an entourage that kinda
like a thing but then but then I did a
bunch of acting stuff too and I've done
Broadway work which was some of it was
similar to my stand-up but I've always
done something that's every 7 years
there's some new incarnation that people
go who the hell is he yeah well that's
why I think it's interesting because
especially with celebrities people like
to just get in or anyone that's public
that they like to just get a kind of
image of you and then just run with that
forever and you're instantly challenged
and Kelly I used to be pigeonholed
because it sounds like something you
should not do to a pigeon now see that's
the kind of joke you guys still do you
can still do that because it's not a
human being
yeah it's a pigeon yeah the only people
are gonna be really upset about that
would be the Humane Society yeah and
they are right the ASPCA is all over the
show
they're just haven't I don't see their
name anywhere anymore I think they're
out you think they're done I don't know
I think it's the ASPCA NRA
I think it's they've combined so that
you take care of the bird and the new
fire at it it's that gonna fly well on
this show I think it will you know we've
got those chickens out there and one day
people always happen what are you gonna
do when they stop laying eggs are you
just women but they're so beautiful I
thought they were males because they had
the red millet malay malay was to call
me and we're very excited to say cockle
I said you have three beautiful [ __ ]
but no those are actually those are
female hens that lay eggs and what are
you doing this for the eggs not just
test Woody Allen yeah which was Groucho
Marx I need the eggs I need the eggs but
that's yeah Annie Hall that's the truth
all right go ahead hi this is the
problem with me as a talk show guest as
a comedian yeah and as someone without a
script I free associate and I sometimes
do not stay on track but you are so
smart and linear you were going to keep
me on track and I will do my very best
to accommodate all right will do my best
to accommodate you okay this is fair
let's start at the beginning you are
born in Phil
Delphia I was yeah and Einstein Hospital
Einstein Hospital yes and it is still
there is that an honor of Albert
Einstein it is huh
it is and it's on Broad Street and and I
was born there and my dad worked for a
supermarket company called Food Fair
pantry pride supermarkets and he was a
meat executive that all sounds legit
what about your family what what
background what business were they in I
was born in Brooklyn grew up in Long
Island lived in Manhattan my whole life
went to college upstate New York so I'm
a true New Yorker so we're both you had
the life I wish I had yeah I was in
Philly I lived at home during college
you had it you had that's why you're
smart and I go out and tell a bunch of
wiener jokes I know but I'm going back
into that now as you know you are you're
gonna stand up I told you I'm going back
in this and you were very excited I'm
excited you also told me you're playing
the Irvine improv yeah and when is that
oh that wasn't even public till just now
that's great okay to say back to April
8th my first headlining gig in 10 years
and this is one of the nicest clubs in
Los Angeles and in in anywhere really I
mean it's it's like six hundred people
seven hundred people it looks like a
spaceship it looks like a Disney exhibit
and it's it's an Irvine which is why
they call it the armed by an improv and
I couldn't put that together why do they
call the Irvine improv and there's but I
don't know but there's smart people and
and nice people there you will bring
smart people because you you have so
many people that you will bring your
audience which is that's the advantage
of what we do yeah whatever we do
whatever media we're on
that's who comes to see us that's got to
be the most beautiful shift in comedy
right do you remember that moment when
you went from like being a guy that was
just you know trying to get on 8th out
of ten comics at the end of the night
nobody knows you are do you remember the
beginning of when people were going I'm
going to see Bob Saget something weird
happened with meit which was I started
doing stand-up when I was 17 and I want
to were that that was a human 73 Wow so
because I'm 104 on the freeway look at
that head of hair though for 100
dope very umbra but I had to do the
drops I take the thing I take
propecia that's push on the propecia he
seems fine oh please don't compare me to
that that's the hair we'll get there
we'll get my sonic comb-over yeah I know
it's gonna happen if we get right on
Trump I actually I I believe but I don't
wanna I'm not doing I'm not doing
anything to bash anyone I will not do it
even though it's possible that his
comb-over is from an onion in the
kitchen that just snaggletooth along the
ground and then crawls up his back yeah
did you see that moment I saw that video
on the airplane yes that done CGI was
that done with effects because that
doesn't look possible it looked pretty
it look pretty fake but let's let's
write with Trump aside I want to talk
Stan yes because do you remember that
moment when when things change yeah what
happened was I came out to LA I went I
had won the Student Academy Award for a
documentary I made about my nephew who
had his face reconstructed when he was
seven and I won this student Academy
Award for documentary and then I went on
at The Comedy Store the next night and
mid to the owner of the Comedy Store
said you should work here so I started
getting spots right away Wow and then I
started then she posed a fight for that
people fight and I didn't work the door
Wow
and I was I guess likeable but strange
very strange jokes like my first joke
was I have the first show I have the
brain of a German Shepherd and the body
of a 16 year old boy and they're both on
my car and I want you to see them now
it's just an odd rambling but it
symbolizes I think it answers the
question of how did he become this
because he was that yeah you're gonna be
third person on myself yeah but and then
I started going on a college tour she
put me on a committee sure for the
comedy stuff put me on a college tour
and I was a guitar act just two parodies
and I would sing while my guitar gently
weeps turn a valve and water poured out
of the guitar and you could only see it
in the first ten rows so it doesn't
really do work for the big stage cannot
play the Irvine improv with this bit
yeah and then I was headlining right
away so in my early 20s I'd go out on
the road while I was taking five years
of acting classes with a teacher named
Darrell Hickman
in LA while I was doing improv classes
at The Groundlings while I was doing
spots at The Comedy Store I'd go out on
the road and then headline and then make
money but not enough to get a career and
then I was like eight nine years of
hosting the Comedy Store in Westwood and
and that was hard it was but I got to
befriend people that I worshiped which
were Richard Pryor Robin Williams and
David Letterman was one of my first MCS
and and so I was 22 years old and this
the place was it's packed like it was
then kind of now bad sentence but in the
early 80s
it was you could not get in to any room
and every single person on the lineup
was like and I was hosting a lot of the
shows so but then everybody went off and
got TV shows and I was still at the
comedy store hosting and thinking this
is it I'm never gonna make it and then I
got in a Richard Pryor movie and then I
got on a CBS show on a morning show
critical condition oh I've seen that I'm
the young dr. Joffe who does all the
jobs that are disgusting that he doesn't
want to do because he's not a real
doctor
sounds like the emcee at a comedy club
exactly the same thing you don't want to
touch people and I remember holding
Garrett Morris from Saturday at live by
the testicles and Richard kept telling
me kept telling me to squeeze harder and
that was a reshoot they added me to that
scene I can see that when you talk about
it sort of and I've had this with a
couple other comics that that were
around at that time there's like a real
nostalgia for it do you remember
thinking it was as special what was yeah
but you remember it at the time thinking
like I'm really in a hundred percent
because usually people don't like the
good old days you only remember them as
well they weren't good old days yeah
because you know you're you're in a
place that is you know in the comedy
starts a lot of history and it's eros is
the main room and there's supposed to be
ghosts in there and Sam Kennison says he
saw a quarter floating in the air of a
dead mobster or something and I believe
all of it I spent a lot of time in there
and it was struggling you know you'd
have people come and see you Rodney
Dangerfield was kind to me
put me on a young comedians special but
it was all you know what I was the
warm-up comic for bosom buddies let's
not hang some personal area and it was
all struggling you know but but you need
it but you didn't I used to wait in line
in New York at the at The Improv and
catch a rising star for ten hours
uh-huh sign the lineup sheet and wait
for 10 12 hours and I think there's
something if you come out of the the
dugout if you really or the trenches
sorry dugouts fine yeah means you're
gonna you're gonna you're gonna bat
maybe maybe but but if you come out of
the trenches and you you go through it
it's almost Oh guy had a heart attack
I've had that happen before you know you
know oh this guy's getting thrown Oh
disco there's a guy's got a gun oh yeah
yeah that happened to me in Cleveland I
remember that yeah you know it just it
gets to the point where you're almost a
pilot on a plane you know it's like I'm
ready for anything
but what you want to do is make people
laugh and that was the hardest
transition for me was to take off the
guitar and to learn to be a comedian
yeah and so it was that moment like for
you really hard I had a guitar on for
like four years I took it off and I
bombed for a long time I would do it I
used the club for what it was supposed
to be used for but it didn't service me
it didn't help me get a sitcom if people
saw me they went he's amicable but he's
not funny and I was trying to do jokes
and a lot of them were there was a
talent coordinator for The Tonight Show
I could never get on as a comic I got on
to do panel with Johnny Carson mmm
thanks to Garry Shandling for putting me
on the first time and then Jay Leno I
was on once with him but then I was on
with Carson 1314 times and then in and
always panel but I never went on as a
comedian because this talent coordinator
who passed on named Jim McCauley who
helped a lot of people's careers except
mine but he did help me in a way he said
you're very funny but your act is like a
stone skipping on the water it never
really digs in ah thank you wow that's
something to really
we kung-fu yeah Wow thank you master
take the pebble from my hand yeah so it
hurt me because I couldn't get her on
the damn show but I wasn't
I really wasn't meant to I mean I hate
to say those kind of words you know it's
not meant to be or whatever but it was a
hell of a lot better to sit there and
talk a couple segments with Johnny
Carson and him like me and be able to
talk to a guy that you looked up to so
much because he was kind of the master
like that like I'm emanating true
jealousy whenever I hear any of you guys
talk about Carson it's like and and I am
not even making this up because I'm not
delusional he liked me
and I still can't figure that out but I
would go I would say something like and
I David Letterman had a lot of his
amazing qualities and it would respond
the same way to this cuz one of my
patters that I would say is this is true
and Johnny would go I don't care yeah I
don't I don't care if it's true just
tell it and David would be the same
thing we go on Letterman and I would go
this is true because I don't care if
it's true or not it'd just make it funny
just say it I'm blanking on the title of
Bill Maher's first book the novel that
he wrote about stand-up but the first
line in it he says something about this
is true which is exactly what a comic
says when they're about to tell you
something false correct and that's how
that's how the novel the hell's the name
of the book I'll get it in a second you
should know you I sure this guy I should
I know him I saw a picture a we are
donated in reading each other's books
yeah he has a read mine either true
story is the name of the book Oh
true story that's that's a branch ah I
also think about this but seriously
folks that is the segue into your next
show yeah our Bob Hope I want to tell
you okay so anyway that's always good
but these are all the tricks so anyway
so I'm in the car well you do learn
tricks yeah you know and if you end it's
always if you can kill them with
kindness or if you can fake sincerity
with their guys during that because
everyone when everyone talks about it's
like you could we could literally spend
the next hour you just naming all stars
right you could just do it but we're
there guys
drop I'll just name drop for the next
and they'll be very easy to make a promo
I'll do that professor Irwin Corey see
no one will know that I know but yeah
but but were there guys that you thought
were true mill heck's transcendent yeah
so a guy like Joe Bill Hicks that's
transcendent yeah that's a guy who
worshipped Sam Kinison it was a friend
of mine I got a mister I got Sam his
first spot at The Comedy Store was it in
the documentary no but he was he was an
unusual thing he was an anomaly it was
no one had ever seen that before and
Bill Hicks really thought about why are
we here and had a sweet philosopher in
him it was a gentle George Carlin kind
of thing mm-hmm I mean from know you
know probably saw a gentler version I
did because I I knew him and he was kind
of I knew him when he was really young
yeah I met him he was like 18 or
something or 19 and he and he kind of
took to me and and his loss was very sad
it would have loved to have seen what he
would arrived at yeah if he'd been up he
died very young because that that's the
type of comic we need more right
especially now like thoughtful like but
guys that are really saying something
like that yeah I mean you know you
getting back in so maybe I'll find him
on well you can't help but reckon with
Chappelle I mean the man is you know
he's also arguably the the best living
stand-up and reminds you of Richard it
was at that time the best living
stand-up might be still Lenny Bruce was
decomposed by being arrested not being
allowed to have freedom of speech George
Carlin took it to another level
where he said I'm cutting my hair no
more and I'm going to let myself say the
things that are on my mind there was a
lot of anger and a lot of prophecy and
people my mother didn't like him because
he was unkempt yeah she wanted a kempt
person yeah she would have loved you
very much
yeah yeah
I don't know very Kemp I'm very Kent
it's a lot of hairspray and she wasn't
he's so smart and he's handsome
all right Saget enough let's tell you my
mother would say but Carlin having that
moment that's like you putting down the
guitar right that's why I think is I
think it's interesting we can either get
good or not it's when you make that move
you like you like learn something and
then you kind of push start all over
again yeah because you get that you get
some chops you figure out what it's like
to be in front of people and then it's
not an effort it's it's a pleasure
yeah I um you know I'm gonna be 62 in
May which is crazy so if you can delay
this that would be great it's not let it
happen yeah yeah but I'm able to go on
stage and I have a gift now having a
special just done that I'm very proud of
this zero to sixty which is from being
zero to being 60s brilliant title Oh
Patty's wordy and it's on Amazon Prime
so my joke is there's a joke with it
they with two clicks you can buy the
lotion to watch the special inferring
that that's how aroused you'll get
watching my special yeah you know i
retweeted your special the other day and
then I think you deleted the tweet and I
thought what happened here did you make
mistake in your tweet I did yeah I made
a mistake in my tweet and then I was
like oh oh oh will you do it again let's
see how the rest of this good okay and
no I understand if you don't want let's
not get ahead myself out but but I yeah
I put something wrong on there because
it's it's on many mediums it's not it's
not a Netflix special but it's on every
platform so it's on I like spectrum
DirecTV Google it so it's never been
done like this till now where they put
it on every on-demand so it's like you
can choose between Wonder Woman or zero
to 60 mm let me think
yeah I've much rather let's Bob than
Wonder Woman that's pretty cool though
that because right we're all in the old
days everyone just wanted the HBO
special I mean I remember the day I
started stand-up I was like I'm going to
have an HBO's I wanted one like God well
now you can have all sorts of other
things
there's
in different ways then and Netflix is
kind of the jewel in the crown so is HBO
but they mostly have a few new people
but mostly they're regular team members
with yeah you know bill or George Lopez
of course who is just wonderful and I
just like George but this has been a
really cool model on being on Amazon
Prime is actually and the world has it
you know so it's I just wanted it to be
seen by as many people that's how I feel
about this thing and like let's just get
it yeah this this is seen by everybody
yeah I would think right as long as
YouTube lets it get to the feed and
YouTube and now so every person that
subscribes you make money no you do make
money is they roll ads on this we make
money but you maybe they roll ads on
this it depends on what we talk about so
you may be deemed too controversial
I'm not controversial I'll go in fuller
house that's on Netflix is a very
family-oriented show yeah what do you
need to sell what product would help you
make money on this well well you know
whatever they want to lay in before this
I don't care what they put in before
that's the funny thing no one associates
the ad with the content you know so they
just want me not to say anything
offensive so that the advertiser won't
say okay Saget talked about whatever
like a fabric softener because they're
Saints one of those sheets that's like a
good thing I would love that fabric I
don't know I like fabric soft it's great
stuff we did and said to me what a
bounce you have on your jacket yeah that
it was perfect perfect brick top outfit
and we complement each other I feel good
about this I am surprised yeah he is I
think we're crushing this house thing
hit it had not heard of it until I did a
little research for this right
apparently it was a big sick huh well
yes it was it was for eight years and I
didn't know either yeah I just do I had
a place to go to work and then I would
paid for kids private school yeah so I
told you this when we had dinner a
couple weeks ago but my sister was she's
nine years younger than me she was so
and I know you hear this all the time
but she was so obsessed yeah with that
show that we were never allowed to watch
TV at dinner in my family that was it we
we would sit and and have a good time or
a bad time er argue or laughed or
whatever but my sister at some point
took control of the fam
and suddenly full house was being
watched during dinner right you were he
loves me she loves damos everyone loves
David yeah it's true everyone loves
naina
no tell me a little bit about getting in
on that and how that differed from
stand-up and then suddenly even though
you had studied acting and all that but
just like doing something that was so
different completely different I'd
always wanted to be on a sitcom I'd been
around them you know I did as I said I
was a warm-up on Bosom Buddies I would
go visit Robin doing Mork and Mindy I
would sneak into Happy Days I snuck into
the Bob Newhart show I was underage you
had to be 16 or 17 I snuck into Mary
Tyler Moore
I would watch some filming these shows
James L Brooks producing Mary Tyler
Moore Show unbelievable and I saw Bob
Newhart last night had the name drop
wants to know when we can go to dinner
didn't mention you that's Don Rickles
that that is a direct lift of the kind
of thing he would say I mean that's
perfection yes that really is comedy
yeah he would say something like
somebody very famous you know I saw
someone last night I saw I saw Chris
Rock last night didn't mention you you
know this just let you know that Rickles
could make it now just because of the
way we are about he was making it in as
a new L as a new young comedian
impossible but there's a new way to do
it which is a way of love and some
people do it and some people make fun of
everyone my friend Jeff Ross is the
roastmaster general you know there there
are ways to bash people but it's turned
mean and what happened is and this is an
understatement
you know the roast I was roasted on
Comedy Central yeah I had John Stamos
was the roast master I had all my
friends were there I got to pick who was
on it
most people don't you know Justin Bieber
roast no one knows him you know most of
the people and people think roasting
people is supposed to be mean and it's a
if it doesn't come out of kindness and
love of the person or just blind I'm
going to attack them but there's no
attachment of anger
this it's just evil it's just wrong and
we are in a society where people will
they'll hit you back on a tweet they'll
watch something you'll see people on the
news you'll listen to political leaders
talk you'll hear people bash each other
back and forth and it comes from Don
Rickles thinking that that's what he did
mm-hmm that's not what the man did the
man would would just you know see a man
and a woman in the audience and say is
this your wife the guy would go yes and
DOM and go oh ho that's just but in his
age had something to do with it but also
his tenacity and his and he started in
the lounge at 2:00 in the morning doing
three shows till 5:00 in the morning
yeah and it talked about the trenches
and all love so if someone comes out and
makes fun of people and does it out of
love or does it had a truth that's the
safest way we're at right now that's
where the Chappelle thing comes to
that's where you look at certain people
I really enjoy Marc Maron a lot bill
burr I mean there's so many people that
are so good that that some people don't
even know about that
sellout places constantly that are just
like Brian Regan it's just he's so he's
brilliant I mean here's three two hours
he's like what and it's clean where do
you go see Seinfeld do what he does you
go that's why he's Jerry site yeah
because it's not just word Smith he's
connected to everything he did it might
be word for word in some ways but
another night but my god it's fun yeah
and you know and then all you know I
love anybody who is funny who just is
there to entertain people and it's not
only about them which is hard because
we're a very narcissistic group right I
mean comics are particularly there's a
certain breed of craziness right that
comes to comedy the best line I ever
heard about that was was I've mentioned
this a few times George Carlin on the
view once and he's sitting there with
all the women around him are you talking
about you know he was giving he
he was selling her they had just come
out with like this anthology so that's
what he was there for but he said
something about how to be a good comic
you have to have a ton of [ __ ] like you
have to have all this pain and all this
angst and all this stuff
but then at some point you got a conquer
it because otherwise it'll conquer you
and that's why it was so many comics
died of drug overdoses and all this
other stuff and so on so are dying young
in art and yeah but if you can own it
then you could be 62 and wow I'm gonna
be doing I don't know if I make doing
stand-up at 90 but I'll be doing forms
of it yeah I know you couldn't stop even
if you wanted to right I could not stop
working III just directed this movie
Benjamin which I'll talk about at length
in the third hour of our interview but
but I have to leave after hour - but
you're welcome - I'm gonna stay yeah
we're just gonna keep going just could
be me and the camera but but I I love
working without it I I'm an artist and
it sounds so Fruity Pebbles to say that
but I just am and I always will be and
I'll be making whether it be directing
or writing or performing I love acting
there's no limit as long as you can
stand and walk and Bend and remember
things you know you know yeah not fall
into an open trunk right the memory one
goes first because now there's guys on
Broadway that are using I appear wigs
yeah I was gonna say IB IB
what's the intercom type missiles yeah
not those that's an N no no that has
been known and I hopefully will live
long enough that at 92 years old I'll be
on Broadway and I'll have an earwig in
and they'll feed me the lunch and I
don't care if I'm good if it's done
right I saw Peter O'Toole and Amanda
Plummer in my fair lady mmm the most
miscast version of my fair lady on
Broadway and I think he had a thing in
his ear he was no child when he did it
playing that character is very
fascinating because my fair lady which
is a play I don't know if people are
familiar but sometimes the audience
skews a little it's it's a tiny bit
older but it's it's not a Millennials
favorite but you know she's its
Pygmalion which of course loses more
people Gen X doesn't even follow
Pygmalion
but it was amazing about it is he's 40
years older than her no matter how you
play that play yeah that is that musical
with Rex Harrison and Audrey Hepburn
he's 40 years older than her he is maybe
50 but he's 60 and she's 20 and that's
that and he's trying to make her a
classy woman in the chauvinistic
misogynistic unacceptable way and it is
one of the best musicals ever written
for people that don't know that was the
original premise of or that was the
original inspiration of pretty woman
right way making that is true
I'm not making that up right no you're
not no you're not he's trying to make an
honest woman yeah out of an honest
hooker yeah all right let's talk about
this full house thing so that right from
honest hooker you did it I was gonna let
you drop one of the girls names but okay
you know so all right so then you
suddenly you're on television everyone
knows who you are yeah what a lot of
money so such a good edit point yeah no
we don't I got offered the job yeah I
was fired from a morning program on CBS
which was against Good Morning America
and Today Show for being too hot for
morning TV
they had another actor play the
character of Danny tanner
I always feel bad about that the clearly
that they Miley was shot was a model of
a shot with Sun House makes me sad but
the same producers and other people in
this business have done that before with
many many shows Robin Williams was not
the first Mork the perfect strangers was
was not Mark linn-baker it was there was
a gay housekeeper in the pilot episode
of The Golden Girls that guy got the
boot i but that's what I played on full
house anyway but but I ended up with the
part because I was fired and they made
it available for me and Jeff Franklin
the exec producer wanted me originally
for it and Bob Boyett and Tom Miller who
still produced fuller house it's a
complicated thing show business it's so
complicated all you want to do is
entertain a bunch of people yeah and
then all this stuff happens and I played
a character because I wanted to be on
three men and a baby had just come out
and we were talking about that before we
yeah we're rolling on this fantastic
showbiz
we saw the gutenberg to dinner that
night on we did see the gutenberg and he
brings his bible and went over almost
here the fish he had the fish and he had
enough for everyone and the water guess
what it turned it to anyway sorry so
this this part was something that I
wanted and three men and a baby with
Stephen and Ted Danson and Tom Selleck
yeah had this come out and so we were
that we were you know Dave and John
David Kahane Johnson demos were already
diapering Ashley and Mary Kate and I was
not in those scenes so they reshot the
pilot and all of a sudden the show ABC
fought that could keep it on doesn't
happen like that anymore they they put
it on twice a week it ran on Tuesdays
didn't run on Fridays uh-huh and then
they started to run it twice a week for
a while and then they ordered more
episodes and it wasn't doing very well
but they believed in it and we were on
against Seinfeld which also wasn't doing
very well right that so that's around
what like eighty nine ninety now at 87
88 oh wow
yeah yeah so then 89 is yes we're not
doing well and then after four years we
started to do well we switched studios
from Sony because I know people want to
give their demographics right on Google
Maps to Warner Brothers to be on the
same stage exactly where fuller house
has done now and did the last four years
there and then it was a really big hit
and of course with network television if
you look at ratings now you go my god
how could they cancel it with that chair
insane and then we were offered to go to
the CW or the WB I can't remember what
it was first cuz it's all a blur we were
offered one more year to go there and we
just kind of said John and I I kinda I
thought we did it you know he could kind
of got cancelled so why do we want to
beg to go somewhere else yes and they do
that sometimes the sitcoms and it never
works right no your somewhere else and
then people find it would they do it for
is for syndication so what years is that
from everything looks different
that looks smaller right but it was the
secret to that show was that there was
actual affection between the cast and
and in good writing and good moral
things where kids could watch your
sister could watch it yeah and feel good
yeah afterward say hi to my sister
Thalia Thalia you were great in Rocky
and that's right that's right
tyre there you go and I just your
brother loves you very very much and and
really appreciates that you would make
them all watch full house instead of
have a nice nice dinner that did make
the dinner nicer all right well let's do
just a little bit more on TV and I want
to talk politics with you and just sort
of live deep you're a philosophical guy
I am a philosophical guy it gets me in
trouble sometimes so you do fuller house
yes big star then you're also doing
America's Funniest Home Videos another
thing where it's a blooper show and I'm
playing on Sunday night 7 to 8 o'clock
at night people were in church that day
so then that night I'm hosting a show
that has to be done very palatable for
America and the world it was number one
in China it was that hard for you
because you I mean you really had to
that that was that was you know it was a
little difficult and it was a gift horse
so the tree opens up you know it's the
number one show the producer Vindobona
called me one day on my curly cord car
phone and said we're number one and I
said you mean peepee anyway no I think I
said where I said we're number one you
know it was a phenomenon and the joke is
if you wanted to see a man get hit in
the nuts you had to come through me I
was the gatekeeper
but in a funny way and now it's all this
I mean it's a YouTube will give you
anything you want that's exactly what I
was gonna say that somehow all of the
stuff that people click that's just
quick and you watch someone get smashed
with something or hit was on your fault
it was all born out of people walking
around with camcorders just because you
guys were like what let's do it he had
the savvy it was a famous show it came
out of a show in Japan which I think are
still partners with that I don't know
the business dealings but I'm gonna look
it up give me a minute
um I'm just getting on my phone you want
to pause you go walking no I'll do it
right here
it became a phenomenon because they took
they did it amazing they did the
grassroots approach which we don't see
anywhere mm-hmm they asked in People
magazine they took out an ad we have a
new show called America's Funniest Home
Videos full-page People magazine send
your VHS tapes and you could be on
television and you could win prize money
and that is how they got the first hour
of tapes and what happened to me was I
was doing a year of full house I get
this tape
they said this is an amicably a young
man the man that now is is Walt Disney
is Bob Iger he is ABC he wanted me for
it
Ted Harbert was at the network wanted me
for it
from full house I seemed like a very
amicable guy they'd seen my stand-up
they didn't care they you know it was
like it wasn't as bluish as I became as
I got more free with myself yeah I was
gonna ask you about that it wasn't I
didn't draw as many f-bombs I just but
it was all weird it all had things that
you can't say so what was that like for
you because he was so there I mean
obviously I'm not telling you that no
but like it was so saccharine the jokes
you'd have to make and I'm proud of them
yeah I wrote it with to the jokes were
two Canadian guys so there was an 18%
exchange rate on the humor but it was
Todd thanks brother
may he rest in peace no his brother's a
lot
Todd Thicke Alan Thicke's brother and
Bob Arnot that's a writer from The
Smothers Brothers show and and we wrote
all the jokes we wrote 55 pages a week I
would do the voiceovers look out oh look
at me you know this bad Mel Blanc who
was that Warner Brothers Bugs Bunny do I
have to explain it to ya millennial
Donal any overdue who's Bugs Bunny thing
after this okay who is but but yeah but
who is Marvin the Martian yeah you make
me so mad
Marvin the Mersenne not a good
impression but it was a big production
too I look I wanted it to be a variety
show so we would have big guests on we'd
have on Rodney Dangerfield anybody that
was a friend of mine we'd add Leslie
Nielsen on Jonathan winters cast a full
house you know we'd have
an hour and and it is still on to this
day a testament to vin and to the people
that make that show you know it went to
Tom Bergeron went through many people
who went through Richard kind hosted at
once Daisy Fuentes John Fugelsang yeah
and there was no way to stop it because
it was a guaranteed laugh and what I
didn't like would would bother me is if
the guy falls in a manhole and then you
see somebody in the audience to other
head back laughing but you never see him
climb out of the manhole I'm like is he
dead right you know so I did that a
charity for people's nuts I Bob Saget
charity for something yeah agates agates
agates something that would have yet
because there should have been people
there were a lot of nut hits it was oh
the good ones were when I was a
six-year-old taking a baseball bat just
jab and his dad yeah even just before
this I was I just quickly put America's
Funniest Home Videos in the youtube
search well it's just not hit after not
hit there's one that's like six hundred
nut hits in a row I mean they just cut
him real quick just one thing that got
to me was someone had sent me a clip
reel that I think they aired on the show
which was old people falling and I had
so and I was like I'm glad I'm not there
cuz that was that was the only time I
went like oh come on and they're falling
on cement and stuff which sounds funny
two bros in a bar dream beers but if you
watch it
it's kind of snuff ish but as long as I
know everybody's okay I didn't want to
be a place where people filmed
themselves hurting their friends so I
felt like I was hurting people right but
that didn't matter
I enjoyed for those first few years of
doing it I just I loved the hell out of
it I mean everybody was talking about it
and loving it I had friends calling me
going what is this yeah because no one
had seen it before but it's interesting
because it's like kind of one of those
things that we don't have anymore like
we don't have shows what we need there
right there are things like yes everyone
watches Game of Thrones or everyone
watches this or that on Netflix but we
don't have like sort of mainstream like
decent things that families can watch
anymore and then oh and it is
nonsense aside you know and that's what
I want to do that's kind of stand I mean
the Thummim talks about a couple
different things I want to do something
a variety I don't know what it is you
know I love directing so I just did this
movie so we knock on wood people go see
this movie Benjamin which we will we'll
get to it for a second right let's get
to it right now
if you want I feel that that was the
right way but I will give closure to
that last thing just saying that I do
feel that there would be it would be
wonderful to have a family
sit down on a Sunday night I mean
wonderful world of Disney used to be on
at 7 o'clock or 7:30 when I was a kid on
NBC yeah and you turn it on now and it's
just another one of those people
punching each other in in big sumo
wrestler costumes yeah and that's not
what I want to see with my family I
wanted to see if that's that's
like--that's I say the cheap replacement
and that's variety yeah that's that's
reality variety but real variety is
we're gonna entertain you and we're
gonna bring out guests and it's gonna be
fun I mean I guess SNL is the closest
thing you have yeah but that's not
really wasn't play them for a time but
you want something you're talking you
want something that's funny but also you
can do some serious stuff you want
saying relevant I mean it's you want
again I have everything yeah but but I
think it needs to make people laugh the
most and then it can have its its waves
in it and so I will be taking pitches
right after this all right let's talk
Benjamin and then Jame Benjamin Benjamin
comes out in the summer it is a movie
that I spent seven years on geez it is
an independent movie very low-budget I'm
just getting hit in the nuts no one no
one gets it there isn't fight in it at
least I can't even I can't tell you who
me and Dave Foley I won't talk I don't
want no no spoiler alerts it's about
it's really about a dysfunctional family
which is most families and we believe
that I directed it and I acted in it
with some amazing people that I'll name
really quickly which are Rob Corddry
who's hilarious kevin Pollak Cheri Oteri
Dave Foley max Burkholder plays my son
he was on parenthood we think that he is
on crystal meth so it's a dark comedy oh
I thought you met the actor no no that's
what movies about movies about
one place Benjamin sorry we believe all
the actors I don't know what you're
doing all the actors in the movie were
on crystal meth during the making of the
in order to be able to survive working
with me yeah because I was out of my
mind because we had a 15 day shoot it
was a low low budget ouch geez yeah I
know this show has longer to shoot my
movie and so my in the movie my son
Benjamin we believe his own crystal meth
and so Marilyn rice cub plays my
girlfriend she's from 24 very good
comedian actress and she posts on
Facebook that we need an intervention
for the boy and that's not where you
post an intervention people don't post
interventions on Facebook it's supposed
to be kind of quiet and properly maybe a
note posted and so Rob Corddry is our
family gynecologist he leaves the
intervention and Kevin Pollak plays my
brother and peri gilpin Xin and Clara
Mamet got to have a Mamet she's so good
at it and David hoo and Jonny Weston and
it's just it's an in samel and it takes
place on one night and it's just
basically the one line would be on it
that the people the person you think has
the problem it's the people and I can't
really give much more a family the
family the your family is the woman the
prow you know people somebody write a
one-line to this movie quick yeah we
need it for the one sheet but the people
that you think have the problem mmm the
people that are accusing someone of
having the problem are the ones with the
problem well that's a spoiler alert
that's a little bit of a spoiler but I
feel like that transcends this movie
that's just a general thing it's a
serious movie with a with a with a
comedy bet to it I know and I'm very
proud of it yeah and so you know thank
you for letting me plug all of that
all right Saget we did career that was
it that was my career is just beginning
literally our career ended my career
completely it ended we never got best
fuller house ever no we did Benjamin
we're good we do Benjamin we you know we
got
stuff coming yeah we didn't even talk
about half-baked but we'll just know
that we'll just say that it never
actually did that in real life my love
never did the real life you know got it
okay alright let's talk I just won't
talk about politics and just kind of
what you think is going on in the world
because that's what you do here that is
what I do here but even though I only
know you a little bit from the
conversation we had at dinner I got just
got a sense that like you actually
you're obviously very sensitive like
that's pretty clear I'm overly sensitive
a little like you want people to be
treated well and fair every think of
myself as a liberal must be well what
did I think I look at myself as a
humanist I was out of plane the other
day which no comedians ever said and
transitory gentleman was on the plane
and he had and he was about 60 years old
and he seemed like a successful
businessman of some kind and I was in
the first class section because there
was a cat back in coach it was a cat for
a case you get sick she had her security
animal to keep her what he called us
animal you know special animal yeah the
main well let's use special needs
yeah animo or whatever but I'm deathly
allergic so I was up front if you cats
do same thing so I was saying to this
gentleman and he had on big bright red
America first shirt and so if I was a I
guess a what you brand is a liberal I
guess that shirt would bother me but I
just looked at the guy and he seemed
like a nice guy I didn't I just said do
you have an allergy to cats he went no
my wife's got a cat I said so you have a
caddy got no my wife has a cat and then
we laughed a little bit and what had
said on a shirt on his shirt isn't a
shirt I would wear it's not where I'm at
I mean I do believe I do believe I love
America I believe that where you live
you want to put first you want to take
care of your people you want to take
care of your hometown
you're coming out with that far-right
craziness or you want to take care of
your country oh but down on the narrow
narrowing down down down down I didn't
turn down but I don't but I'm not if
you're if you're kind and you're not out
doing some closeted hatred or blatant
hatred I don't know but I just look at
my dad's whole thing was be kind to
people so it sounds like a pacifist
might bother people but that's what
we're supposed to do yeah is the problem
with that that you just get nipped off
by both sides I mean I see that a lot
now that I do think there's this
interesting Center developing I don't
even know other's sides I mean I of
course yeah of course I do
yeah but you know and the and people go
well you're a Democrat right now I'm
like I'll vote for anybody that can get
us out of this mess
you know I bring my dad back from the
grave and vote for him he'd be such a
good candidate it'll be a Grateful Dead
video yeah I don't know try agree where
are you when you consider yourself a
liberal is that where you are yeah I
still consider myself a liberal but most
of the liberal things that I believe in
I can pretty much explain from a
libertarian perspective right and that I
just don't want the government involved
in my life that's it and I think you
should live your life however you see
fit and I'll live mine however I see fit
like you have a lot more money than me
right fair to say I don't know but we're
gonna do spreadsheet exams right after
this is over let's be clear I'm on
YouTube you've been on network
television you've got three chickens
outside I don't have three chickens I
don't know their value but you could
have chickens the point is I don't
deserve any of your stuff just because
you make more money than me right I
can't have any of your money it would be
nice I suppose but I don't deserve any
but that's what taxes are about and
that's where our incredibly rich society
and our incredibly poor society are at
odds with each other and that has been
since the beginning of time since you
know castles were built with a dictator
and a king living in it yeah and
everybody had to go build all this stuff
and they were slaves so I mean it's it
does the metaphor doesn't change
the representation doesn't change that
the downtrodden are downtrodden
and are disgruntled and then other
people are angry at things that that
they should just take a freakin chill
pill over yeah
well that cuts an outrage thing well
there's a lot to be outraged over also
because all the the problem with you
know wanting to entertain people was
wanting to be a comedian is it's nearly
impossible when there's so many deaths
when there's so many tragic things
happening which there always have been
but we are at a news ratio where it's
coming at us you just you know you hit
your computer on and it says you know
news alert and you hit news alert and
you're like you're afraid to hit the
button you're afraid to get up in the
morning hit whatever news service you go
to so that's just a matter of us knowing
about it more because I have Steven
Pinker on next week who's a Harvard
psychologist who and his whole argument
is actually that things are better than
they've ever been abusing empirical
scientific evidence about the amount of
people that are being exposed quicker
well because we actually have more
people out of poverty now worldwide than
ever before more people with drinkable
water than ever before more people that
live in mobile environment Enlightenment
values and everywhere but we see more
people with drinkable water yeah more
than not around the world no way around
the world more now than ever before well
that might be true is that are we
hundred-percent that's true I'm pretty
sure that's true but what about what
about more people being murdered what
about the safety of our kids what about
you know all these things over because
most of those markers actually they're
better than ever before it's just that
we hear about them all the time now
right and we obsess over them not and we
and we obsess over the negative yeah
because we're not presented the positive
and if we're presented the positive it's
through a skewed broadcast it's it's
it's not really presented by someone
that comforts you this show comforts you
more than most shows
because of the way you handle it that's
just a fact you're trying to have
watched use several times you're trying
to put two factions together that might
have similar or opposed views discussing
opposed views and are saying why can't
it be like this because if you try to go
toward an idealistic goal the dream of
it is how you can almost get there
that's that's how the country was
founded besides you know taking a lot of
things away from the people that lived
here that's a whole other show that
you've got three [ __ ] in your yard
pretty good so I just try to get you out
of this now let me I'm not really
politically astute but did I make any
sense yeah well you are making some
sense but I think you actually are I
mean you're around Mara all the time
what that must be I saw just last night
and he said Aloha because we were in
Hawaii together yeah but I do say that
I'd rather get my news from you know
from John Oliver and and Bill Maher and
Stephen Colbert and Seth Meyers and
Jimmy Kimmel then the newscasters what
does that tell you about just media we
we need a relief and so the news itself
is already a parody and it's also so
obsessive no matter where it's coming
from and we're also dealing with a
regime which flip-flops in the media and
on Twitter faster than it's ever existed
because we never had a president tweet
us you know this just did we did I mean
Obama did but right but it wasn't it was
it like I hate this I love this you know
18:21
you know 21:18 it's like Aaron Vegas
yeah you know just double down do you
see him as the problem though or is a
symptom because I really see well I
think that the symptom he is a symptom
it was it was voting for a guy that was
on a show that said you're fired
so what do you expect to get you know if
you're gonna if you're gonna get the
host of America's Got Talent
you're gonna get the most out of people
it's good to be the the best procession
ever it could be dancers and singers and
yeah if you had been the president
people would be getting big jokes no you
you would for me I guarantee you a dick
joke a day and I would tweet them and
not three in the morning I do not tweet
well three in the morning no one should
know well no one except the president
because but but I just think you know
what did we expect but I think a lot of
people were surprised and I think it
doesn't matter it's happening yeah and
this is it and so we want a better
humanity and there are great people in
the world
and there are great people in other
countries leading the world the best
they can and there's a lot of slackers
and there's other people that are just
part of the political bunch of crap but
they're still great people and there's
great people watching this there's nice
people watching your show yeah you're a
nice person nice people you don't I
don't think you get a lot of haters do
you get live in a ridiculous amount of
haters you do yeah because I talk about
the problems that I see with the modern
day left and the Liberals and they don't
like someone to address those things
that was once one of them but I got this
great fake manner why can't they they
don't fall they don't fall for that well
I like a perfect shrink come on could
you could calm me down through tightrope
walking that was because we slipped a
little thing in your water there is
something in my water I'm feeling
different yes notice the tone is change
I'm not leaving I'm on the show tomorrow
are the walls vibrating it
oh yeah our buildings moved in yeah
there anyone there is an eye chart
behind you you know that it says Los
Angeles but it's an eye chart pretty
clever huh yeah that's really it we call
that art Zagat well done mr. bond pretty
good is there anyone that you're paying
attention to these days that you think
is making some sense because I
appreciate all the comments but the
compliments but like that's what I think
I'm doing here is just trying to make a
little sense of something to me to be
honest John Oliver has been I can't
think of anyone political that has made
me go well there is a great hope there
and I'm interested in something
some people have to say that seemed wow
that was noble but they're not gonna do
anything about it or they're not gonna
run or but I'd like to think there's
someone out there you know I'd like to
think you think that's part of it that
we all talk a lot but we don't do I
sense that's sort of what's happening
here yeah so is that everyone's saying
[ __ ] that's all it is
we're fighting always just a bunch of
[ __ ] voices it's frequencies
everywhere gone all through our heads
it's just noise so trump was like all
right I'm gonna do it none of you do
anything and Trump's like all right I'll
do it I'll run for president you morons
and guess what he was right yeah and the
way he does it he can turn anything he
wants into a rally if he feels the
moment and he gets the right South Park
background behind it yeah but he's doing
it and I don't know I just don't know
anything it's too you can't predict a
thing and we want that security is
feeling secure that you know at least
what tomorrow brings we don't know what
an hour from now brings we have never
been on our haunches more not knowing
what's gonna come out of him out of the
White House who's gonna get fired but
that's not the issue the issue is
where's the world at and where's our
kids at and where are the things that
really matter what really matters is
people this is sort of like you're
giving me the ending of a full house
episode and you know I want to tell you
something else honey I don't want you
drinking beer at the prom and you cannot
have a horse in the living room this is
where the synthesizer music yeah yeah
and you know what always follow your gut
because your guts not wrong if you feel
it deep inside then take imodium because
any moment there could be a release I
wish I could have done full house like
that that would have been nice I didn't
give you a chance for bloopers like that
where you could just oh their bloopers
yeah no I agree with that I said
horrific things yeah theirs is I wrote a
book called dirty daddy and i stoled I
talked about something I did on the set
once and I got in a lot of trouble but I
won't say what it is because
it's not repeatable on this YouTube
channel but it is in that book and it
was something I should not have done
with with a well I can't I can't say it
but it was something that happened
because then okay I did something that
we had stand-ins for the kids that were
mannequins and I was alone on the set
with just the crew and the monitors were
on and I didn't know that not acceptable
under these conditions no or under this
time do you ever worry about that
because you you still I mean no because
everything and someone goes Oh someone's
gonna come for wins
when's your being bad thing gonna come
out I don't know look at my last special
yeah you want it it's right there in a
weird way that's like you're it's like
you're saving grace sort of like you
know I am a confessional yeah I mean as
a historian in there in zero to sixty
this special where I say I was given
ludes by a club owner which were serious
drugs it was a like a roofie terrible
drug from wolf of wallstreet Jonah Hill
and and Leo DiCaprio and a club owner
told me to give it to a waitress and I
could have my way with her and I instead
to cut to the chase and ruin a joke I
actually took it myself to knock myself
out so because she was kind of hitting
on me because I did it too that's kind
of guy I am so all my stuff's out there
because I didn't I didn't do anything
diabolical that I can recall that is
being yourself
right can you yes yeah can you can you
add that I can recall to every single
thing I said on this entire interview
that's what politicians do okay so I'm
gonna come in and I'm gonna voice-over
this new hire interview yeah that I can
recall yeah I feel we should end this
either with something hitting you in the
nuts or some song oh yes we could do a
song but you already gave me the nice
full house ending what do you think is
you you are the one here with the brain
tell me what you think is the hope of
know how this how we
you know is is communication yeah that
this is happening now that people are
doing this that you know what I mean
your divorce your fiancee Kelly came
across me we traded a couple messages on
Twitter I was like oh she gets it like
she's trying to find some answers I'm
trying to find some answers and she we
went out for dinner we all became
friends immediately
yeah and that people and that whatever
difference is that we may have we're you
know you're probably still a little more
left than I am on some things or what
just doesn't even matter yeah mine I
think on some things probably you're
probably a little more yeah I know it
doesn't it's a relic I dress left no no
no that counts it just doesn't even
matter but the point is that that the
reason that shows like this are working
is because of this that you were willing
to come here sit down I wanted to come
here yeah yeah you immediately said to
me that you wanted to come but that's a
point it's like people want this now
they are so tired of the other thing and
all we're doing is exactly what Tom
Snyder did and he was just talking to
the camera but or what cause he had a
guess or William F Buckley or any of
these people who said let's try to find
some answers and you can get I think as
many answers from Bob Saget as you can
from the guys I get I think you get far
more answers from listening to someone
like you who has some life experience
and that cares then you can virtually
listening to CNN all day long well you
can get what we never got into which we
don't I don't want to get into which is
all the death that I had in my family so
much death of friends I just lost
someone today it's just I think it's bad
luck well all I was gonna say was that's
what centers everybody because the
things we all go through our birth and
death and they all happen differently
and when they happen at an unfortunate
age like I lost two sisters at 34 and 47
that's that's what centers you that's
bigger than everything is the loss of
life and when people die when young
people die there's nothing more that's
all that matters yeah the rest of it is
your belief this is that this is that
it's yes you want to solve in a
civilization how to keep people alive
but the empathy is what
missing and just quickly to touch on
what we didn't touch him but we talked
about before the show started okay I
like the talk shows that exist at night
to chat shows as they call them in
England when I would do Johnny Carson
show and before him was Jack Paar who I
got to meet and before him was Steve
Allen who I got to meet and these are
guys that they all had The Tonight Show
those gentlemen and then Johnny ended up
with it that was viewed how they would
tell their guests you're coming to a
cocktail party mm-hmm how do I dress
like a cocktail party how do I talk
you're at a cocktail party you're in
Johnny's living room and he's sharing
that living room with everybody well why
does he have a desk in his living
because he wants a desk he wants a place
for his ashtray he smokes got a little
maybe he's got a drink there whatever
that's why I don't believe even that
that they used to do that I mean I
there's a lot I can write what they're
smoking they're drinking you know Burt
Reynolds is wasted I mean it's amazing
and that's not what we want we don't
want to see it although sometimes we do
we see some strange things that happened
I mean Letterman certainly had some you
know Joaquin Phoenix moments those kind
of things we're still gonna see more
stuff like that people are gonna do
whatever trippy stuff they're doing but
the truth of it is those late-night
shows are supposed to be entertainment
that's what they're supposed to be
they've become a bit of let's attack
everything today yeah that we've been
through because look what happened today
because it's been getting ratings and
people that necessarily might not do
political comedy like James Corden he's
an entertainment oriented man he's been
very childhood man from Broadway he's
does care at carpool karaoke he but he
comes on does some minute monologue that
might have a bunch of stuff in it about
the White House but that's not he's not
born to do that but that's what's
feeding the beast yeah but it's supposed
to be a time where you chill at the end
of the day where you're entertained
where you relax and when you want to get
that Tom Schneider when you want to get
that dare I say the name in a sentence
Charlie Rose because that's what he did
he did a one-on-one but when you say a
name
like that it can't help but cause
someone to recoil because they Larry
King for my purposes Larry King I've
known forever and I adore ya he's a
great guy Larry King posed to have
dinner with him Kelly and I are supposed
to go ahead with him and Shawna out for
dinner we can go to that place if you
invest on that place that we went that
place away with that we don't talk about
yeah what does like that place he is
quite a character he I went on Lion King
show he read my book and every time he
sees me he goes I loved your book Saget
and I don't think it's because he he
forgot that he keeps telling me but he's
just I've just known him a long time
yeah and and he was very very good at it
you know and we've got we have some
really good people doing the news
there's some real good people out there
I mean Lawrence O'Donnell is a friend of
mine III like him a lot
that name right there might flag people
yeah it will MSNBC yeah and too many
consonants we hate it but I I don't know
I I just see we need to be entertained
it's really complicated to do it at this
time in a way without bringing up human
issues moral issues and I'm gonna do the
best I can to do that you know it's
funny I remember so I was never even
though I think you know him personally I
was never a fan of Leno on The Tonight
Show I loved Carson even though it was
my kind of very early years but Leno to
me I always liked the Bill Hicks thing
more and you know they had that rival
and I like that sort of more raw
morality and Leto to me was like he was
just the corporate version so I never
liked it but in an odd way I suddenly
had this bizarre respect for him now
well it was a comedian hosting the
Tonight Show yeah and I mean that he
wasn't overtly political all the time
now it's always political and I almost
missed that in a way even though he
wasn't really my guy in terms of comedy
but I know I know everyone says he's an
incredible stand-up which is nothing to
do with is a great stand-up I was an
intern on the Mike Douglas show Wow
within Philadelphia at 18 years old and
I was on his very first television
appearance Wow so I know Jay that long
and so there's a interesting history and
then you know Johnny
Carson David Letterman Conan those were
guys that I would go on those shows and
I felt the most connection but Jay I
would go on and promote a movie I had
worked on that I directed that I worked
so hard and he couldn't have been more
gracious you know so yeah I don't you
have to be Kimmel is one of the sweetest
people alive that does this you know and
Colbert's great I mean it's an
interesting time for media and for
broadcasting I just want to see us get
into some kind of place of peace a mind
in the world and we're not there that's
a big lift man I mean that's right like
that's why I'm doing this that's why you
want to I think do this I've never
wanted to do so I've never wanted to
perform more I'm more motivated to go to
stand-up I booked the stand I'm on tour
I'm trying to work out trying to come up
with new stuff because I you know you do
a special and you deplete it but you you
know you don't want to just give them
something they just bought or heard but
people really need it and I need to do
it because it takes people out of it
brings them into their life you know the
Atomics are like the last cents makers
these days there's a couple others that
I think there's a few there's a few
comedians that I would rather watch than
almost anybody there are some good
motivational speakers there's some good
good clergy out there I'm not a
subscriber
that much well I'm comedian so I kind of
listened to the people that have a lot
to say and some of them really do have a
lot to say so I respect I respect people
with a point of view that aren't
malicious now be you did we do it all
here I think pretty much unless you want
you got a walk you want to make some
festivals I do have a great walk I knew
you had a walk only one disaster story
one like just nightmare I was telling
you before about my my thing when I was
on at the RNC convention and I was
sweating like crazy and Larry King said
it's much more like like Albert Brooks
in broadcast news I was on station to
take us out with the disasters
a disaster of stand-up of anything give
me some life very well think it's give
me a professional not a life disaster my
guy gave you a life disaster you how
about one life name their name dropping
like disaster yeah I'm on an airplane on
America on a 747 I'm on the video show
which is number one at the time so you
can then list famous people on the plane
in the newspaper by who's the most
famous and now they're listed in the
newspaper but I was on a plane with
David Bowie and am on and Greg Kinnear
and Richard Lewis where was bad this was
an American flight out of JFK to LA
that's Larry and also mark McEwan who
was on the CBS Morning News and a friend
of mine and so the plane starts taking
off this would never exist today as
we're taking off in the air we hear an
explosion and one of the engines
apparently blows out the plane goes
rickety we then land at JFK this is a
very long time ago
and we find out first they take the VIPs
which is people I named on two carts and
Richard Lewis is yelling with next to
David Bowie only a couple of us are Jews
I'm like that's not not to this so now
we're in the club and I'm getting to
talk to David Bowie so I'm going okay
this was worth than explosion I'm going
and who could not have been more
gracious and and it was just it was
dangerous and upsetting they two hours
go by they put us back on the same plane
turns out it was a fuel hose that came
loose which is just like turning a screw
on a gasket on your lawnmower and they
fixed it which would never happen now
they would get you a new plane or cancel
you completely or whatever right and we
then took off and I made some joke I
think the movie outbreak had just come
out and I said something like there was
a monkey caught in the in the engine and
then Richard Lewis yells out that's a
good one Bob Amon is from Zaire
and so I'm called out then as we take
off Richard Lewis yells thanks Bob to
the whole plane and at that time you can
go into the cockpit this is probably
left but you know you know yeah of 9/11
and I was able to ask the pilots what
happened
so I actually told the VIPs no one else
yeah what happened but they didn't tell
the other people so that was that's true
disaster story I mean that could have
ended incredibly badly and I would have
been fourth I would settle that with
Lewis because we could we could get him
here and we could moderate some
discussion last night in he and I are
gonna we hold him by the face and hugs
me and we're gonna figure out the list
but he's gonna tell me that I would have
gone ahead of him simply because of that
dumb video show but he would say dumb
video show in order to to do it because
that was the probably 1988-89 you know
it's one of the one of the nicest
moments I've had on this when I had
Richard Lewis anon and he left and you
know he's kind of a germaphobe is Larry
and you know he doesn't shake hands he
does this because he said goodbye to me
I walked him out and when I opened up
the door he just he said seems like
you're very tanned he touched me on the
cheek and I was like I like melted I was
he does this Rabbinical thing is that
what that it was an erotic Rabbinical
thing that I think he learned from his
shrink probably the other story which is
a very simple one very very short story
I was in San Francisco performing
stand-up I learned that be careful what
you do messing with a heckler a guy who
was about eight feet tall got up on
stage and got me in a headlock
holy [ __ ] and wouldn't let go of me and
had me and was hurting my neck badly no
security nobody there no it is and I
took the microphone and I shoved it up
his ass and he got so paranoid that I
had done that that he ran away I don't
know why all I know is I don't know if
he had a homophobic frightened moment or
I thought maybe that I was going to go
further in or maybe that he would have
farted and I would have picked it up on
the mic but in any case that is scary
when you are out there with
people now young girls will just flash
me their boobs and go Danny tanner
you know like that but I've had a few
things like that happen where people
have had to security he's had to throw
people out you get all kinds of stuff
like that that won't happen to you an
Irvine at the improv I hope not
you've got a hell of a stand-up career
happening because you have something so
you say content and then you have jokes
you're gonna have you're gonna talk
philosophically like you do on here
about life yeah and then you button it
with something humorous or you feather
it throughout with jokes yeah I mean we
talk about it a little bit but I'm you
know there's two ways sort of that you
could do this so there's the Seinfeld
way which is like that perfect tactician
laid out every pause every inflection
point I can never do it that way I don't
think that's exactly how you do it
either no but then there's sort of a
Garry Shandling way which was you know
there's that great moment in the
documentary comedian where he Jerry
shows him his papers and it looks you
know Hitler wrote it cuz it's like so
perfect and then you have Gary Shelley
who pulls out this crumpled piece of
paper don't believe that's much closer
to what I am I have some ideas and I did
I was on a beach last week in Florida
and I wrote out the hour and some of it
is stuff that I've done through the
years that I've just updated but it's
all based in what I'm doing here and I'm
trying to just be true I'm just trying
to be trilling I'm gonna be great yeah
and then you're then you're hooked I
know then you're then you then welcome
to the next 30 years and it'll
infiltrate it will infiltrate this and
might not only be stand-up and you it's
an interesting thing to do to be able to
go hey I'm gonna do Vegas three times
this year and and you know people come
to see me and it's kind of fun and can I
get on the jet with you and Mar you know
what if I if I rock it for the next year
that'll be my goal you saw the picture I
saw the picture yeah you don't want to
be on that you can take it you don't to
be in that one that was that was a fun
trip that was a fun yeah you guys do
that every year you and Martin I've
never done it without four he always
says he has Eddie Vetter do it who comes
in and we didn't know he had him on tape
and he had Reggie Brown who did his
Obama impression that he's done on real
time before and then he always has
different people he gets different
comedians to come out and do it with him
and he asked me to do because he wanted
to have some fun and we've always liked
each other
I mean we known each other since 4:23 we
all started together
I took Jerry Seinfeld to Disney plant
and Garry Shandling and George Wallace
and it was the opening of Thunder
Mountain Railroad and I'll leave you
with this because I've left you with
nine other I don't want to keep going
now - yeah but there was a goat with
dynamite on if you're a bit on Thunder
Mountain Railroad I know it but I'm not
why does it exist anymore oh it's very
popular yeah so if there's a goat with
dynamite a robot not you know not much
of a robot but it's a tronic exactly
with a dynamite and you hear it's and
all I did for 23 years old and Jerry's a
few months older than me I think
I want Jerry oh my god a goat with
dynamite and Jerry with Jerry always did
was just lay out the obvious oh my gosh
I glass was a stain you know your mats
not a joke or I'm not him because he's
we groaning there's nothing a clean
glass but but he to this day I could say
oh my god ago with dynamite and he will
laugh because it's when you you know
somebody and you just get them you know
and I saw a bunch of comics last night I
saw Paul Reiser and it was Billy
Crystal's birthday and it's just nice
seeing all these people that I yeah
really it's so magical that time right
like you came up in a time that to me
and for anyone that appreciates comedy
it's like holy [ __ ] all of these guys
and then you realize there weren't that
many you go like oh there were thousands
of convenience no there weren't there
were hundreds and a lot of them are gone
and then there's you know I'm at that
two-thirds point I'd like to think my
middle chapter I means I have to tell it
to 122 well with all the medications
these days I think it's possible
motorized unicycle up my butt with no
seat that seems excessive but whatever
whatever works for you and we lost
Stephen Hawking just wanted to end on
that dick wait you mentioned George
Wallace George George was his HBO
special which I think maybe he only had
one which is a real disservice although
he's had many other specialists to me
he might be the funniest half-hour
there's something about him and he is
was always a friend of mind always a
Brenda Jerry's yeah he's just a funny
funny guy and he would mess with me one
time he was opening for Tom Jones a lot
on the road and I lived in Hollywood on
Camino Palmero and he went out of town
but I forgot that he went out of town
and we were buddies and and and he said
he called me up he said Saget make me
chicken I said ok I had no life you know
I was waiting for the Comedy Store that
night you know I was 20 for me ok I'll
make you chicken what do you want to
sell them fried in an oven ok sure make
me make this make me chicken I'll be
over in a couple hours
so I make him chicken make a whole bunch
of chicken and then he doesn't come over
and now I'm getting worried William
Holden had just died and so I'm like
scared that George died in his condo
shows you I have grown yeah as a human I
called his landlord and I got ahold of a
building and he said George's and Tahoe
he's nobody behind John so I called the
hotel and I said George what what did
you do is you [ __ ] idiot I told you I
was opening for Tom Jones why'd you make
me chicken
I said I'm freezing it you're gonna eat
it damn it so that's the end of that
story
the George Wallace never eat your
chicken no I ate it it was pretty good
on that note Saget I haven't made
chicken since until I came to your house
and I saw your the way you were
eyeballing the one on the left you can
have an egg you can't have the chicken
okay can I have an egg yeah you can
leave this house with an egg I wonder
I'm gonna give you a farm-fresh egg
you're not happy the way you cook it
you're not happy that'll make my sister
Bob Saget Danny Tanner is walking out of
my house with a farm-fresh egg
but-but-but can I eat it
yeah this is debate know what I will
cook it you know what David's the chef
around here do you want to literally the
best sunny-side up egg you yeah all
right we are ending this show that this
really has been a pleasure like it's so
nice when you meet somebody who you know
Sam
but you don't know and then you realize
that you know them something like that
that's the point I think of what we're
supposed to do is people and we get to
do this and we would do this at dinner
this is almost like it was except we
just we would move more we didn't move
very much I was like you know Captain
Pike a little bit yeah
all right I suspect we'll do this over
dinner again and yeah we'll do it here
again and and ah this is I think you got
enough to bear this for three years this
is this is the longest show this is
actually my retirement show now how long
was this we about six hours that's
fantast
know that really this was beyond we went
into mountain time for more on that man
Bob Saget check out his special
zero-to-sixty on Amazon and we've got
the link right down below
[Music]
you
[Music]